[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to policy
punchline here the show we interview
scholars policymakers and business
executives
about some of the most urgent issues and
frontier ideas in our world today
i'm princeton senior tiger gao today i
have the pleasure to welcome david
pakman who
hosts the david pakman show and
internationally syndicated television
radio
and internet political program he
started the show in
2005 at the age of 21 and began hosting
at a local radio station as a hobby
uh but by 2011 uh the show has aired on
100 stations and outlets and he was for
some time
the youngest nationally syndicated
political host uh
well mr pacman thanks so much for
joining me today it's
a great pleasure to be able to talk to
you thanks for having me
uh i guess we can before we dive into
some more questions about the media
landscape and
politics today would you mind just
telling us a little bit more about your
journey with your church
with your show over the years and also
uh your unique
business model right now because i know
you have a large subscriber base and
that's
uh how you get the message out yeah so
the show started just as like a single
community
radio station in northampton
massachusetts when i was a student
an undergrad student and then i just
kind of kept it going
as i was in graduate school and
eventually what was a one station radio
show became a syndicated radio show
and then a syndicated radio show and a
youtube channel
and a tv show and it sort of grew over
time
and now it is um you know on multiple
platforms
my business model is one of of
diversifying revenue streams so that
we're not
too at risk if any one revenue stream
were to fail that's that's sort of the
business side of it but from a political
perspective the show is just uh it's
based around my views which happen to be
um
socially democratic left-wing views by
any reasonable assessment
um since you mentioned about your
political views maybe we can
uh jump right in in the past couple of
months there's just so much
i guess socio-political turmoil and also
many recent developments whether it's
the coca-19 crisis or
uh the the black lives matter movement
so i guess how would you categorize the
state of the socio-political discourse
or consciousness of this
nation right now and by discourse i kind
of mean the general norm that dictates
how people interact with each other or
basically the way that politics is being
talked about uh
in in the media or in private because i
i guess
among all the famous podcast hosts ezra
client would probably say that you know
we're making
strides towards progress uh eric
weinstein would probably say we're in
the middle of a cultural revolution
and ben shapiro would probably say we're
in the middle of chaos or or
so which part of the spectrum would you
be on
where do you think the country is at
right now interestingly i am very much
not anywhere in line with ben shapiro's
politics but i
tend to agree with him that it's chaos
um but but maybe for different reasons
than
than he thinks so i mean my my kind of
30
000 foot view right now is that
over the last i mean really since ronald
reagan and the
uh idea of the welfare queen
with 10 kids driving a cadillac from
from that point forward
we've seen a sort of debasing and
coarsening of political discourse
anti-intellectualism
pseudo-intellectualism and it pervades
almost every aspect of society
um you know there's a debate as to
whether it pervades academia
maybe academia has some more resistance
to it
but if you look at the way that the
current president speaks
if you look at what counts as an
argument and what counts as
as valid debate if you look at
the disconnect that exists between
discourse and facts where facts
no longer i i hate to say
are no longer necessary because in in a
kind of
real sense of course facts are necessary
to have serious
policy debates but facts aren't
necessary for many
in the united states to come to
conclusions conclusions that are very
difficult to change and that
link directly to how people vote so i
think that the state of affairs is very
dire right now
i guess to quickly follow up on that
part about facts
um i personally worry i guess not the
fact that people
do not use facts to arrive at certain
conclusions but rather that
they can't find any facts they want um i
mean i guess kevin conway
famously used the phrase alternative
fact but i guess in today's world
alternative facts do exist right you can
literally google
any kind of facts or statistics that you
can find
that supports climate change or does not
support climate change and such and so
on so
um do you worry that the fact that
google or this kind of uh increasingly
frictionless
access to all kinds of information is is
also kind of at play right now
eroding the the social discourse we're
changing
hugely at play it's hugely at play but i
think that if we
you know there are there are folks who
focus their analysis
merely on social media algorithms
filter bubbles and echo chambers kind of
creating a never-ending feedback loop
where if you already have a certain view
you are likely to continue encountering
news
articles and opinion that reinforces
that view
and it creates this insular bubble as as
the name
suggests of course that's part of the
problem
but those algorithms only have the power
that they do
and those filter bubbles are only as
insular as they are
because we have a very significant lack
of
fundamental critical thinking and media
literacy skills which could and should
be taught
starting probably uh to 12 year olds and
if you bring that framework into the
political space
and young adulthood you're far less
likely ever to fall into these rabbit
holes
that are dictated by social media
algorithms so yes
i consider the online you know the
frictionless access to whatever
perspective you want
that's uh a consequence of the deeper
problem
i guess maybe we could go slightly
deeper than that
not just in terms of education because
you've famously said
on your show and also in your other
interviews that there's a difference
between
i guess getting passionate about
universal health care uh versus
shutting down abortion clinics across
the country so so you you refuse to draw
kind of a false equivalence there
between for example
the extreme far left and extreme far
right and um
what extent do you do you believe that
you are correct to what extent do you
believe in
um the set of facts that you have access
to to what extent
uh how have you arrived at your set of
beliefs and believe that you are
more correct than the other side well
before we jump into that just one
correction you know you you
kind of i think part of the problem is
the way that the overton window has been
falsely established you you mentioned as
an example of far right
ban all abortions and as an example of
far left universal health care
europe would not think that universal
health care is far left so i think it's
really important that we
you know in this conversation not fall
into a sort of a false
uh framing of of the political spectrum
but listen
i'm not special in any way in that
i am subject to the same cognitive
biases and heuristics that
anybody who understands you know
behavioral economics
and psychology would would be uh subject
to
confirmation bias filter bubbles uh
you know all of there's no question
about it my
goal is that understanding these
would better enable me to try to uh take
a sort of
outside perspective and say hold on a
second
i i am aware of what these biases are
let's see if i can pull myself
out of them and try what's the strongest
case i can make for the other side for
example
or what what is the weakest part
of the facts i'm using to come to this
conclusion
and again i think that if you are
exposed
to the basics of epistemology
and critical thinking and media literacy
at an early age hopefully
you integrate this and it's sort of like
a personal
scientific method right where different
from the way many
um religious environments work
the scientific method encourages proving
wrong
the pre-existing beliefs and i i
try to be open to that as a starting
point
i i just think it's really hard to get
to that place where
people are educated in in terms of media
literacy or
critical thinking be for example i go to
princeton i have a lot of friends who
are
who would be considered you know ivy
league educated you know very well
educated very privileged students and i
think
uh a lot of times the way we derive
we get most of our facts are from like
instagram stories the instagram posts
uh that obviously are have certain
often have progressive messages that are
helpful messages uh that are trying to
shed light on some kind of issue that is
helpful to the society
however after all they are you know
quote unquote simple statistics that are
you know
that do not really get to the bottoms of
the layers and layers of the issues and
and
and i worry that because this is even at
the nation's top university and i i just
don't see a way out in terms of how
um social media or or can can people can
pull themselves out of those
this kind of loop yeah i mean there's no
easy solution i mean every aspect of
society
is tailor made for you know you look at
instagram and 15 second instagram
stories that people are getting facts
from you look at the presidential
debates where they're going to be
you know 90 second 60 second even 30
second answer periods i mean that's just
at every level
there's this debasement and and over
simplification of really complex
issues and there's really no one
solution to it but that doesn't mean
that motivated individuals
can't get closer to what we might
objectively call the truth i mean one
example i remember from my uh
um so the last few years of politics
is the issue of the gender pay gap which
is a very contentious
issue and you have some on the right who
say there is no gender pay gap
you have on the left for a long time
this number of 77 cents on the dollar
that was
bandied about and intuitively we could
say
probably there's something wrong with
both of those perspectives
but saying that the truth is probably in
the middle is often not going to get us
where we need to be and when we did it
you know we spent a month researching
this and really looking at the serious
scholarship on it for
for a piece that we did and what we
found was there is a gender pay gap
um you of course have to be comparing
the same
type of work uh and the same level of
career experience
and once you do that it's more like 91
cents on the dollar
and of those 9 cents some
portion is likely due to gender
discrimination
so the right was wrong 77 cents on the
dollar
is wrong but we don't just say the truth
must be right in the middle
that's i think where both sides benefit
from
from making their position as extreme as
possible to bring
the middle towards their side and very
often that's not that's not
where reality sits and the fact that
the truth is in the middle does not mean
you should not try to come up with
helpful policies
to adjust and make up that the rest of
nice sense
which i i agree so i guess the the
follow-up question to this kind of uh
you said people's attention spans are
getting shorter we're reduced to
um you know quick debates rather than
you know back in lincoln's time
people go on hours and hours debates on
on very sensitive subjects so
um we're seeing this rise of long-form
podcasting you
uh part of it joe rogan famously does
those three four
hour long podcasts the millions of
people listen to which is which is uh
mind-boggling how people can actually go
through this kind of long-form
conversation so
um how do you categorize the the media
landscape right now because it's being
increasingly fractured and we're seeing
this rise of independent media like
yourselves
uh what are your thoughts on this
disruption do you think
it's a positive influence that the more
people are having this kind of long-form
dialogues finally making up a gap in the
traditional legacy media
yeah i i think that the availability of
so
from a technological standpoint the
internet has lowered barriers to entry
where anybody with a microphone can
start up anybody with a phone can start
a podcast or a chat and you know that's
great that that's of course
unbalanced that's good uh with that
of course comes the caveat
of needing to be prepared to distinguish
from what is real and what is not real
we're seeing this with
written articles and you look at you
know fake news that was shared
during the 2016 election it happened to
be over
disproportionately shared by older folks
and disproportionately shared by
right wing folks that's how it was in
2016
could be different in other times and
uh i i think that you know narrow
casting which is
creating a program that might have a
much smaller
potential audience but a very engaged
one you know programs about
aviation or programs about chess
or billiards or whatever your total
potential audience
is smaller but the costs are lower
the financial sustainability threshold
is lower all of that is fantastic
the darker side of it of course is that
with
relatively few financial resources
programs that look and sound very
professional can be put together
even when they are disseminating
debunked propaganda
xenophobic and racist ideology etc
can i don't want to use the term trick
but
it is in a sense a tricking of people
into thinking that it is
equivalent in terms of its
trustworthiness
to an actual well-researched
media outlet and that's sort of a darker
side to it
um i i remember you talking on your show
how you don't brand your show as a
neutral space
you say but i'm being as transparent as
i am i
reason through my beliefs and i present
all my facts and
and basis from which i derive my beliefs
to my listeners and therefore you have
a decent number of people on the right
who probably
would disagree with you but because they
respect the way you arrive at your
beliefs they come listen to your show so
i i guess your program
kind of presents your opinions very
front and center
how do you think talk show hosts or talk
shows in general
can present their beliefs and and not
compromise on what they really believe
in while still being able to offer very
coherent arguments
and potentially engage with the other
side without
alienating them or demeaning this i
think it's a very tricky balance right
it's there's there's no recipe for it i
mean there really isn't and
there are a lot of different you know
one of the things that you learn when
you study media literacy is when we talk
about bias very often people talk about
just political bias like are you on the
left and pretending to be in the middle
are you on the right and pretending to
be in the middle or whatever the reality
is there's all sorts of different
biases that can happen you can be biased
because you have an editor
who is uh ultimately the person who
decides you get to talk about this or
you don't so the bias may not be yours
it may be your editor's bias
there can be advertiser bias where
you're limited or influenced in what you
say or how you say it
because of what advertisers have to say
so you know we we don't have to go into
every single example but
i think the point is that my
um priority is just to be transparent
in terms of listen i'm on the left
there's no advertiser bias
i don't talk to my advertisers they've
never imposed on me i can or can't talk
about this
there is no editor there you know
the the bias is i'm on the left and
that's my perspective
and i think that that transmits a sort
of good
faith uh perspective for argumentation
and it doesn't mean
we won't disagree but at least we're
eliminating
some of those other factors
can we talk a little bit more about i
guess your the relationship between
platforms and hosts like you because in
many interviews you've
alluded to the ongoing debate over how
to regulate this disinformation for
example on youtube and
um many years ago there was this famous
ad apocalypse thing that that
really happened this stirred a lot of
controversy and even in this coma 19
debate there are
people who are on twitter who initially
posted things that are contrary to what
the government or cdc or new york times
were saying
and those people some are later proven
to be right some proven later to be
wrong but
i initially personally helped believe
that maybe we should
let the government take down any
disinformation about kobe 19
from twitter but later i thought what if
the government was wrong in certain
respects
just like how how trump or or cdc was
initially wrong in some of their
assessments so
how do you see this dichotomy what do
you think about
a disinformation or potentially this
kind of very decentralized uh
mechanism of spreading voices and
information
well you know one one thing to note on
that is that a lot of the controversy
was not so much about
whether the government should be able to
take content down
but what's the right standard that the
platforms themselves should be using
because a lot you know with the donald
trump tweets that were flagged as
suppressing the vote for example that
was twitter's call
uh it was not any kind of government
entity that was doing that
and these are two different things right
what power should the government have
versus what power should the platform
have i think this is a very complicated
thing and i spoke about this with joe
rogan
which is i think intuitively a lot of us
understand
that there's a spectrum in terms of what
we consider
an open platform which is you literally
allow
anything you allow anything that's not
illegal
in some way or it's just sort
of up to the platform or it's up to a
government
or it's up to some community flagging
system every single one of those systems
could be misused conceivably and there
are major legal questions
and and you know if you say well here is
how twitter is supposed to run
as per the government what's the legal
infrastructure for that
right now certainly there's legal
infrastructure for
if you want to be in the insurance
business here's the the rules you have
to play by
if you want to manufacture vehicles
here's how the auto safety
standards are done right so you would
have to create some kind of new
infrastructure and when you do that
it's subject to the whims of the
administration
you can say well no no in order to
prevent a republican from doing it one
way
and then a democrat from regulating
social media another way
you create a nonpartisan commission with
three democrats and three republicans
do any of us really feel like that's
going to to achieve what we want to
achieve so i think it's a very complex
uh
question uh a complex question
that you personally would say that you
have not arrived at a concrete solution
or i haven't no i really haven't i mean
i think that uh so there's kind of
there's it's a two-step process we have
to go through the first step
is let's really understand what the
infrastructure is now
so to say now the government can tell
youtube what videos to keep up or not
there's not a legal infrastructure for
that there just isn't
so right now businesses
like youtube and facebook and others
have their
own laws they have terms and conditions
they can enforce them
the the limit to that would be if the
the rules are uh explicitly
or implicitly discriminatory on the
basis of protected classes that would
exceed the limits right now
so if youtube decided that they were
going to regulate content in a way that
effectively discriminates against black
people
or seeks or whatever then now you've got
a legal issue
then the question becomes do we want
and what would a new legal
infrastructure look like
and how would it be regulated and i i
just i don't have
i've not found any satisfactory
infrastructure so far and i guess
maybe we can limit the scope of the
problem a little bit more uh
let's just say in this cova 19 crisis in
the past six months
back in march at the beginning of the
phase when the data
did not seem to be that solid people
didn't have a concrete understanding of
what was going on
uh and now there are people maybe in
seattle or wherever
different cities different pockets of
people organizations that start saying
uh wear masks helps wear masks don't
help uh you should wear this kind of
mask you should you should not do this
and that
all kinds of information or about drugs
or whatever
um do you think that twitter or the cdc
so so either either the private company
or the government authority either a
partisan authority or a non-partisan
authority
should come in and say we should flag
these we should take these
down because people are reading these
things and
they they they would die if they make
the mistake right
so a couple different things first of
all i think that
for the most part what we've seen from
social media platforms
has been good faith now there are some
people who will say
you know youtube pulled some stuff from
some
skeptics that you know it's unclear
whether it was really acting in good
faith okay
we could debate the edge case but 99 of
what i've seen
social media platforms doing has been in
good faith
trying to mirror what our understanding
is at the time of the science
now you are accurately pointing out that
the view on masks really for political
reasons
changed where you know they didn't want
to create a run on masks
but then it was like the masks do work
but then now it's unclear
okay if things if if the best
understanding of reality changes i think
it's
good that social media platforms would
change how they are regulating the
content
that's good faith that's the scientific
method it's an error correction
mechanism so i don't really have a
problem with that
if we believe that they're acting in
in relatively good faith the the problem
is that you know when the president is
spreading disinformation
when the science says one thing
even the president's own scientists say
one thing and then the president says
the opposite what is it that social
media platforms are supposed to do i
think that they always opt in favor of
science that's my view
but you start to get these complicated
situations where people start to allege
political bias they start to allege you
know an agenda
an agenda that is you know make things
look worse so that trump loses that's
one that
has been you know now put forward um
you know then you get into stuff like uh
what kind of
incentives yeah uh exactly and so
so that that gets uh more complicated
but again
99 i've seen that the social media
platforms have tried to stick to what is
the best science we have at the time
uh would you say twitter i mean twitter
has been accused
of suppressing uh right wing voices for
a long time every time any of those big
tech executives go on capitol hill they
get grilled by republican senators and
then
congress people about these things so uh
from your perspective we're based on the
people you talk to
do you think there is a do you think the
big tech
in silicon valley are somewhat in any
way
biased or or even actively consciously
unconsciously suppressing some of the
right-wing voices well unconsciously is
more difficult to say i think there's a
couple different issues here first of
all
um you know a lot of people like to
point to
the um employee culture
at some of these tech companies to say
that these are fundamentally left-wing
companies and you know the fact that
there's casual friday or no dress code
or you
should really refer to people by the
gender pronouns that they prefer
that's that's sort of called corporate
culture
that is different from whether companies
fundamentally share an anti-regulation
perspective
because that's good for uh profit and
that
these are really different things and
this also came up the first time i was
on with joe rogan the idea of
you know google is a left-wing company
they have these policies about you can't
misgender people at work
well hold on a second look at google's
regulatory record and their lobbying
priorities the
google is a left-wing company these are
corporations that seek to return
seek a return for their shareholders now
then you get into con
um and one that's often brought up is
twitter's view on misgendering people
um you know if if twitter
says at this point uh the trans
community
is part of our community and
we're gonna have to make some judgment
calls but if you're deliberately
misgendering someone who's trans
that's a form of bullying and we're
going to do our best
to enforce that the right
would say that is anti-right
discrimination
a lot of people would just say it's just
like we don't allow bullying on the
basis of race and we don't allow
bullying on the racist on the basis of
religion and
the world has evolved and we're not
going to allow it on the basis of
misgendering people so
the problem is that what counts as
bullying is disputed by some
i i was just talking to a friend that
day and i think it's really
interesting that uh silicon valley is
liberal
and well california or silicon valley
are filled with
very liberal left-wing people but a lot
of individuals
as individuals yes uh but a lot of the
right-wing theorists all have roots in
california i mean whether we we
see it's uh uh eric weinstein or or
i mean he's not right-wing i guess
people that are
counter-narrative counter-mainstream
culture peter thiel
joe rogan even even someone like stephen
miller who is very very counter
mainstream so i
i guess this also kind of goes back to
my initial question
about this rise of independent media
which is podcasting but also within
podcasting
there is a growing strand of people that
are considered
very very counter narrative like joe
rogan and i i i
how do you make of this group of people
uh that might not preach
the most commonly accepted social
democratic ideals
uh but they identify themselves as
progressives where
like like joe rogan where everyone stand
they'll say i vote for bernie
i still want to see social changes but
they're now like uh
as our client they don't agree with this
kind of you know
over correction pendulum swing to the
left and and
uh radical social change type of stuff
what do you make of this i i guess as a
pot a podcast host yourself
being in this circle um seeing this
trend of
counter culture counter narrative well i
mean one
one thing as a sort of setup is that i
question this idea that there is this
radical pendulum swing taking place of
radical social change you know and and
when you go there you're only half a
step behind trump's
anarchist cities and you know chaos in
the streets and
and you know all of this type of stuff i
think that
one of the things that's tricky for
people who occupy these spaces
including in podcasting if you spend a
lot of time on twitter reddit etc
is the same thing that happened during
the democratic primary which is you
start to get a skewed view of what the
country is like in general
and support for bernie sanders was
dramatically overstated
on places like reddit and twitter and
joe biden won the primary by millions of
votes
so i think that we would need to check
ourselves and this is why you know i
have
regularly scheduled breaks from online
and i'm you know reading
books and looking at other types of
publications
to try to not lose touch with the fact
that what i see on my subreddit is not
america necessarily um so that's sort of
one thing
in terms of you know counter culture or
counter narrative
i think that that's all great and that's
part of what uh
what the internet has done in terms of
lowering the barrier to entry
i would feel better about it if people
were more educated and better able to
discern what makes sense and what
doesn't make sense so when you start to
see
you know conspiracy movies about corona
documentary
movies i don't even really call it a
documentary conspiracy films
videos about coronavirus spread like
wildfire
if you have a more educated population
that says i'm not going i would be
embarrassed
to share this on facebook you cut a lot
of that
out and that's that's what's on the
other side of the risk
i have no doubt that this is a net
benefit in total
but we would be much better off if we
had a population that was less
susceptible to some of this stuff
counter narrative is great
conspiracy stuff not so good you know
just going back to the very first part
of your response when we
said you kind of disagree with this you
know pendulum over
swinging narrative uh
there's been so much i guess talk about
this thing in the past couple of months
i guess in the middle of the summer
uh the harper letter people were talking
about how academia
was censoring right wing wing voices uh
here at princeton
um there were many students who wrote
letters basically saying yes black lives
matter but
here's the thing those are campus free
speech whatever and and people students
on the left will say that that's
absolute bs you're you're dodging the
question what is this kind of
free speech under threat type of thing
so um
what do you make of i guess that period
of of social change social turmoil this
i guess another
shift of rapid shift of social cultural
norm academic norms
and i guess the second part of the
question would be this narrative
about overswing of the pendulum because
a lot of people do cite evidence of
saying
it's absurd how you your tweet from 20
years ago gets
dug up and your somehow career gets
destroyed and things like that
yeah i mean so the truth is that we're a
country of 331 million people the number
of people whose careers have been
destroyed by it
i mean it can't be a 20 year old tweet
right i don't think twitter was around
20 years ago but whenever
the number of people that that's
happening to is very small there are
cases where
it probably makes sense where an
organization
where sometimes comments are so vile
that any association is toxic
other times these are youthful
indiscretions
mistakes views that someone has recanted
and said i don't stand
by it so my view on those situations has
been
if the argument is that thou remember
331 million people in the united states
if the argument
is that even thousands of people are
having that happen to them
i've not seen the evidence for that if
the argument is
we should be thoughtful and careful
whenever something like this happens and
really ask ourselves
what was the context of what was said is
this relevant to this person
and their role that they are in today i
think that we
we can't take a one-size-fits-all
approach to that
but to get to the first part of the
question
what i reject is not the concept that
when the pendulum
swings far one way it eventually swings
back the other way
i you know in some uh general sense i
i agree with that what i reject is the
idea
that things are uniquely out of control
that the culture is changing so much
faster now than it has before i mean
these are very similar arguments to what
we heard
in the pre and during vietnam war era
of hippie culture and counter culture
and drugs and free love and all of this
stuff
and it just it's one of these tropes
that keeps coming up and again
i think people who spend a lot of their
time on reddit and twitter
will overstate the degree to which these
things are happening
or in other words uh when someone goes
on fox news and brings up certain
evidence a certain incidents those are
often very isolated cases
that are being exaggerated and sometimes
people are posing this kind of straw man
um argument that that it does not hold
in
when putting at a large scale uh i tend
to agree with that
but i guess uh since you're someone on
the left and i guess
me personally i'm also someone probably
tending towards the left i guess
um what would you feel like to be
an urgent problem of the the left right
now because
obviously when uh people that are on the
right
when they watch fox news uh or when
people that are in the middle
who often agree with the left but you
know somewhat counter culture
maybe are not entirely uh agreeing with
the left
when they talk it often seems it's like
oh my god there's
barry weiss resigned from the new york
times this is this kind of
narrative driven journalism oh oh my god
there's a censorship of academics
on campus it all comes back to this kind
of discord that's why i guess
going back to my first question to you
at the beginning of the interview which
is the state of the social discourse and
socio-political discourse in our country
today
um do you think there's there's a
problem on the left when it comes to
this kind of discourse
i think there are problems on the left
and and so i identify them and i talk
about them on my program so some
problems on the left right now and again
whenever you talk about a problem on the
left
you're talking about a problem among
some on the left it's not
if the it's not in total because still
for the most part i
that you know the ideals that i support
are on the left but
problems that you can find on the left
include um uh
a sort of uh apathy that can set in
uh or a feeling of um
the inability to accomplish anything
when things don't go exactly our way
and we saw this in 2016 when when bernie
sanders did not win the primary
fairly or unfairly you had people who
were saying ah you know if hillary and
trump are two sides of the same coin and
it sort of doesn't even really matter if
i vote what the supreme court
uh i don't think hillary would choose
people that are significantly different
than the people trump would choose
that has been widely disconfirmed by
what we're seeing
right now and that is an aspect of
some on the left that i think is very
problematic
i think that the american left sometimes
has a blind spot
when it comes to some economic ideas
where
you know i'm a social democrat in the
northern european tradition
for sure but having an understanding
of uh you know neoclassical economics
keynesian economics
it's not crazy it doesn't actually work
in reality as described but i think it's
important to understand it
to then add behavioral economics to it
and add these other things
um i think that some of the social
movements that we've seen
like the women's march will allow in
elements that i think are completely
destructive there were anti-semitic
elements
in women's march leadership which
completely to me went counter to the
stated goals of the
organization and the left is not to my
some on the left are not quick enough to
call that out and to say we don't need
debt and it's counterproductive i think
sometimes on foreign policy there will
be people on the left who
you know whether it's on syria or russia
or china or whatever
you know they they sometimes are maybe
missing the boat a little bit so yeah i
mean there's no shortage of criticisms
uh of of the left and they're different
than my criticisms of the right
but to go back to maybe where we started
the criticism
that at some kind of
systemic level the left has gone crazy
demanding woke cultural change if you
look at the democratic
party which right now still is the locus
of power for what is ostensibly the left
in the united states maybe that'll
change
that's not what is represented in the
democratic party
uh and i guess just to cite your podcast
episode from literally yesterday
september 22nd
you were saying that the far left does
not give
the quote-unquote centrist left like joe
biden enough credit about
how progressive biden's policies how
much meat there actually is when it
comes to
improving people's lives and and shifted
the overton window and such and so on so
i forgive me for for being so over
generalizing when it comes to using the
term
quote-unquote left but uh maybe we can
talk
slightly more focused about the leftist
media i mean
all the outlets from new york times two
independent podcasts
like yours uh do you think the the
leftist media has become
this is again a very unaccurate word but
quote unquote lazier
after trump's election in the in the
sense that
because of trump's personality flaws and
because of gop's
very unreasonable use of partisan
politics it's just so
easy right now to simply group all their
policies
uh by the administration or on the right
under this big umbrella of being whether
it's racist or xenophobic
in other words there are cultural
scripts that i see the leftist media
often use to fit in
for example if trump bans tick-tock or
wechat
um instead of talking about the policy
let's first talk about how he's a racist
which i think is not very helpful so i
forgive me i have not seen one story
saying trump banning tick tock is racist
uh i'm not saying that those stories
don't exist but i've i've not seen
uh i've not seen any um i think
that there are times when those
narratives
are correct and times where they are
wrong
so trump's position on health care uh i
don't think is racist i don't think it's
xenophobic
i think it's just bad i think it's
unempathetic
i think it's bad economically uh i think
it's immoral
um you know i i don't think that
it's necessary to uh sort of go to those
other characterizations
um from everything we know from what
michael cohen and
others have said and the way donald
trump seems to relate to minorities
he's probably a guy who's not
particularly enlightened
on uh racial issues i think to to put it
lightly and i think that that's a fair
criticism to make now
even if he were his policy on health
care would still be a disaster so
i think maybe what sometimes i mean not
to go totally meta
what sometimes is lazy is and i'm not
turning this around on you
but what sometimes is lazy is to
try to make such a vague critique
or or general critique of leftist media
i mean even saying the new york times
is leftist media listen the new york
times does not like donald trump
the opinion pages do not like donald
trump 100
but the new york times has an
investigative
journalism department that is
is uh you know top top-notch
it's not failing the way donald trump
says they're doing better than ever and
i don't think they're doing better than
ever
because they're lazily saying everything
trump does is racist i think they're
doing good investigative journalism
yes yes um i completely agree and i
guess to
quickly uh dragged myself out of the
hole i
dug for myself i i did not mean to say
trump's ban of
of tick tock or or certain abs per se
are are racist but i guess
some people sometimes people say the
fact that trump banned
wechat is unnecessary aggression towards
china or towards
the chinese people or whatever but such
as but well that may be that
that doesn't mean that it's xenophobic i
mean there's a you know trump has
embroiled himself
in a misguided trade war while
continuing to use terms like china virus
and kung flu
and now on top of that you could
certainly see some of these other
actions as part of that it doesn't mean
it is in and of itself
you know a racist or xenophobic action
but it's certainly part of
of the the mobilization that he's
participating in with regard to china
yes yes and i guess his whole persona of
yes um can we talk a little bit more i
guess about the the election that you
uh famously said that when you
talk to people that you really disagree
with when you try to lower down the
the temperature you often ask how do you
think i came to my position
what evidence if i present to you would
bring you to my side
so maybe i could ask you what things if
any would you need to see in order for
you to vote for
a republican president in either in this
election or
or in next well i mean the thing is so
what you're suggesting is that their
their
donald trump may have secretly done a
lot of things that are great that we
just don't know about right i mean
that's ultimately what you're saying
this is a bit of a different situation
because the reason i'm voting for joe
biden and not donald trump is i've seen
what donald trump did for the last four
years so when you say what
changed my mind had donald trump had
a different presidency than right but at
this point
it's you know if trump cures cancer in
the next six weeks
and uh yeah i mean it's it's it's sort
of like like a
kind of wacky thought experiment this
close to the election but
as a general principle all it would take
for me to vote for a republican over a
democrat in any particular race is for
the republican to be better suited and a
better
option on policy i see where i i guess
the
what i was try really trying to get is
it's not rather what would make you
vote for donald trump in the next 40
days or so but rather
uh what changes would you like to see in
the republican party that you would
feel like okay this is a party that i
might feel
slightly more comfortable uh uh
agreeing with in more policies what are
some of the things that you would like
to see
oh sure i mean if they completely change
their economic policy
instead if they completely change their
approach to climate change
if they completely change their approach
to the you know the military-industrial
complex i mean these are these are
really big things
you know i i think that the more sort of
realistic thing would be that you could
have a local race
where you have you know maybe an
establishment
centrist democrat who's getting nothing
done
and not showing up and then maybe you
have kind of an
up-and-coming republican who's socially
liberal and maybe a little bit to my
right economically
but that for strategic reasons i might
prefer you know like that's a more
realistic scenario i think for me
uh so zooming in a little bit on this
particular election in the next
40 days or so um how confident are you
that the election
and the potential transfer of power
would happen
peacefully or smoothly because there's
so many studies who have come out and
said
uh short of a biden landslide will
likely end up with a constitutional
crisis not last
until the inauguration you know with
violence in the streets severely
disrupted administrative transition and
probably
uh years-long court battle just because
of the middle invode and coronavirus
that that is really happening right now
and and um
and you've talked about this on your
show but i i'd love to hear a little bit
more of like is your
solution or because i guess one time on
the show you said
the biden team really needs to talk with
their lawyers and figure out a way to
to battle this in the courts but it just
seems so difficult to me
because if the republicans have this
somewhat irrational
suspicion of middle and fraud and and
they would try to declare the the
victory on the election night
and most of the million ballots are you
know the blue sea
uh yeah it seems inconceivable to me how
this
this will play out smoothly i think it's
very unlikely that it plays out
smoothly i mean i just don't think it's
very likely now what that means in
practice it could mean different things
to what degree are we are we talking
about you know so there's a there's a
bunch of different things that i
think are likely to happen and it could
be some or all of these
different things uh the simplest would
be that uh
the red mirage scenario where early in
person voting favors trump
and uh if all of the absentee ballots
were counted
some of some states would switch to
biden but at midnight on election day
trump's army of lawyers which we know he
already has retained
will do everything they can to stop the
counting of absentee ballots
that's one scenario uh another scenario
that is in the atlantic this week is
that
um typically each state has electors
on standby for each candidate so if
trump wins michigan
certain electors go to dc i don't know
if they'll go this year but
you know they go to dc to vote for trump
if biden wins michigan
democratic electors go there's a new
technical argument that has been
suggested to the trump campaign
which is you know regardless of who wins
michigan
donald trump could still say send
the republican electors this is going to
be a legal battle
it could be a complete and total mess
and you know people can read more about
that
in in the atlantic this week um
i i don't know what to expect i think
it's going to be
unlike any transition period we've ever
seen now the other scenario would be if
trump wins by a landslide right
and in that case if it's believable that
trump won by a landslide despite the
polling
um that may be less
uh it might be more smooth but i i do
think that there's going to be some
degree
of friction just to put it lightly
so most of the polling results we're
seeing right now uh
suggest that byron are probably leading
by double digits and he'll likely win
the the
the general election so let's just say
that
trump would do everything in his power
to not concede the election
uh and therefore what happens partly
would depend on
whether his party backs him up if he
attempts challenge results and such and
so on so
if biden if there is abide in victory
and the trump uh
refuses to acknowledge it do you see the
republican party finally
standing up to him or accepting defeat
and i guess i i asked this question
in a dramatic change of context because
uh justice ginsburg
just passed away very unfortunately and
and we saw that mitt romney
uh yesterday tuesday uh uh september
22nd
decided that he will vote for trump's
nominee
which showed this tremendous and quick
rallying behind the president's back
even for someone like romney because it
aligns with his interest
that he sees conservative principles and
policies to be
implemented despite his own personality
state of trump's personal character so
i guess in that sense would the party
still stand behind trump
for the party interest even though they
know
okay this is not the right thing to do i
think they will
and just one clarification all mitt
romney has said so far is that he would
be willing
to have the vote he didn't say yes i
will vote we don't even know who the
nominee is yet i think that's important
to clarification
i mean one thing to remember is there's
not there are some polls with joe biden
having a double-digit lead
the average lead is seven for joe biden
right now
and that's still substantial but 12
becoming two by election day is not
super likely
seven becoming two is more plausible and
so i think that the
the important thing is you know there's
always these discussions of does my vote
really matter
uh my state will definitely go blue so i
don't need to vote
or my state will definitely go red so i
don't need to vote
that's like the exact wrong idea it's
never been more wrong than this election
and i think that we still have to count
every vote and everybody needs to
figure out what what is their path
forward now
whatever the results are if donald trump
claims victory
um i think that is if if it is even
remotely credible that there was
an irregularity even if it wouldn't
really have flipped the results
i believe that republicans will
overwhelmingly fall in line and say yeah
yeah yeah this this uh something
trump's right i think by and large
you're going to see them fall in line
i guess the greater question here would
be so many have said that the republican
party has
effectively become the trump party to
what extent do you think this is because
of trump's alignment
with core conservative interests such as
the tax cuts such as
court appointments and people like ben
shapiro who used to
did not like trump and now say i would
vote for trump because he has
enacted conservative policies to what
extent do you think is because of that
versus the inability of you know
quote-unquote true conservatives to
stand up against trump
i uh i don't know that most
conservatives really think
trump has actually done much on policy i
think that they've basically put their
eggs in two baskets
one is the we definitely don't want
democrats
controlling anything right so we don't
want democrats in the white house we
don't want democrats choosing supreme
court justices we don't want democrats
controlling the senate
that is so powerful for many republicans
that they give trump a pass on policy
and then number two judges it's not just
that trump is likely to get a third
supreme court justice
hundreds of lower court judges
and it is something that is going to
shape the justice system in the united
states for
for decades and i think that because of
that they just
you know they'll either defend or just
not mention the insanity of the things
that donald trump does i think it's that
simple um we talked about
the the statistics of um biden's you
know seven point lead over trump we've
talked about the
scenarios of mainland voting and such
and so on
i know you are not a probability
theorist or statistician but
how would you predict uh the actual
chance
of biden clinching this presidency
in this cycle i mean given all the
instability and turmoil that will
actually happen
so given that i'm not a statistician
but rather a political realist i believe
we have to consider it
um essentially 50 50. wow i mean it's
listen you know what does it mean to say
it's 70 30 for biden 30 is very high
if you run a 100 simulations that one
person wins 30 of them that's a lot
that's really a lot so so i think that
in practical terms
either candidate could come away the
victor is the only way to approach this
yes um i i guess we're coming to a close
soon because i know you have to go uh
are you optimistic
or pessimistic uh about
the future of this nation i i mean i'm
i'm not particularly optimistic right
now
like in this moment and certainly what
happens on november 4th
could you know it'll be a slight
adjustment of the trajectory that we're
expecting but um i still maintain
the general idea that
in the next that if you look 20 years
from now things will be better in 20
years than they are today
that that's that's my very general sense
how we get there exactly
and it may be you know meandering in
some way it may be a meandering path
but that's where i am and i think that
there's just kind of a
wishful thinking to some degree but also
when you
you know if you look at most metrics
every 20 years
most things have improved over the last
20 years
in some general sense there are still
problems to fix
we do have a significantly powerful you
know ideological right-wing movement in
the united states but
there are many institutions that you
know have
have pushed the ball forward in many
areas of life that affect our day-to-day
globally this is not like the utopian
stephen pinker crime is down
poverty's down things are but it it is
true that in a sense
um you know life expectancy on balance
is growing
abject poverty is decreasing i know that
there's counter arguments individually
to every one of these aspects but that's
what's sort of keeping me moderately
optimistic right now
to what extent is your pessimism or or
optimism affected by your day-to-day
engagement with politics because i know
if you are in a political environment
within the stock market markets where
things are happening at a very high
frequency rate and
so much noise and there's so much crazy
things going on how do you maintain your
sanity
how do you how do you derive your
conclusions about the long-term
development of this country from more
fundamental
things rather than yeah i mean it's it's
again it's reading history sociology
psychology
economics and looking looking at broader
trends and not
uh looking at you know a daytime
financial television that tells you how
the dad did today i mean it's really
about filtering out the noise it really
is
and um you know taking three days a week
where i'm not really following politics
and i'm reading history and economics
and doing other stuff i mean i think
the interaction with the political world
makes me pessimistic because
unfortunately there are so many
uninformed people that i come across and
i say
if this is 60 million people in the
country that's not so good
um but then you look at the broader zoom
out and things look a little less bad at
least hopefully
i hope you don't walk away from this
interview you think that if this is the
princeton student then where it works
so i i guess two quick questions at the
end one is what would be one
contrarian view that you hold that
people on the left
or or might disagree with and the and
the other one is since the name of our
show
is policy punch i just want to ask you
at the end what would be your your punch
line for
for this interview so so i mean i think
contrarian
there's a lot of people on the left who
still believe 77 cents on the dollar to
go back to our
pay gap thing and when i talk about it's
really 91
there's a lot of people who just say no
you're wrong and
um so so just for sake of argument i
i would pick that i guess and your
policy punchline
i don't know i'm so bad i mean listen my
show is called the david pakman show
because i couldn't come up with anything
more
creative my policy punch line is um
uh you know things are pretty good in
norway
let's look to norway let's look at some
of the things norway is doing i guess is
what my policy punchline is
well thank you so much mr pacman this
concludes this episode of policy
punchline please
uh go visit uh mr pacman's show
davidpakmanpakman.com can
subscribe become a subscriber for for
five or six dollars a month
uh you can listen to him on all kinds of
platforms and a truly fascinating
interview
uh thank you so much for for joining me
today my pleasure thanks for doing it
[Music]
you've been listening to policy
punchline a podcast generously supported
by the julius rabinowitz center for
public policy and finance at princeton
university
we would also like to encourage you to
follow other podcasts produced by
princeton university
such as politics and polls by the
woodrow wilson school of public and
international affairs policy punchline
is intended to be informational only
and does not reflect nor represent the
views of princeton university
or the julius rabinowitz center for
public policy and finance
for more information on subscription
donation volunteering or contact
please visit policypunchline.com thank
you again for listening